yeah the muscles are fine crispy crab
always coming through crispy crab with
the K the big time to us on Instagram
didn't they know they commented on us
they having the kind of big time to us
we like shouting them out and they like
liked the comment if I did something
they didn't follow back though she want
some muscles
dude I'll go to I'll go to mr. and mrs.
Crabb I get like a pound of crawfish
they just give it to you like a grocery
bag right big-ass bag yeah not really
big-ass grocery bagging like they give
you like a bucket like gloves and [ __ ]
but I like to get my fingers you want to
yeah yeah yeah okay plate [ __ ] the
gloves
I don't even bro like I don't even use
the bib because they give you like a bib
yeah you know I'm saying [ __ ] that I'm
in there bro fingernails dirty all that
you don't do what you played video games
though right you do why you playing
video games eat the [ __ ] crawfish
while you're playing like skate three
okay no bro like what was like the
biggest pet peeve for me when I was a
kid playing video games with my brother
my older brother in like he would be so
messy like eating hot pockets
[ __ ] grabbing the controller that's
there's like a hot pocket juice all won
the [ __ ] joy and play video game I
mean that's not even that bad a hot
pocket or like a pizza roll your hands
are still getting greasy as [ __ ] there's
[ __ ] pizza roll grease all on the
controller chances are there's a
mountain this kid this kid that we know
he's a professional Fortnight player he
eats crap just like this from crispy
crab while he's playing fortnight like
he plays on the computers he got like
the keyboard in the mouse and he's got
like the full-on like garbage bag over
his body with the holes in it for his
arms you know I've seen this picture of
this kid he's playing for at night and
like he has his feet like his toes are
like pointing up against the wall like
his back is up against the wall like
this
and like he's like it's kind of like
some Airbender [ __ ] bro the way he's
playing what he's levitating yeah bro
like my nephews are really good at that
game too are they they eat sleep breathe
fortnight bro like they do once you ever
Pleasant is crazy
are you but it's like I gotta already
like be playing for a little bit like I
got a warm up for ya yeah I got my
nephews
they'll be on that [ __ ] all day like
literally like like when they come stay
with me for a couple nights brodo be up
until like 5 o'clock in the morning just
yeah yelling on the microphone I'm like
it's so addicting that [ __ ] game man
man like I don't remember a game like
that when we were young how about the
Travis Scott concert James Bond halo was
for sure yeah
I think years hello yeah gears and halo
was like the game of my generation we're
like kids were just gears 1 crazy
buses what about quake quake that might
have been early 2000s yeah yeah that's
all right yeah yeah I was like my era
was like 2006 yeah eh yeah and then
Splinter Cell I was really addicted to
splinter yeah yeah Rainbow six yeah yeah
Tom Clancy games I got it I got a ps1
and I have the original Rainbow six and
like like I'm stuck on the first school
like what the [ __ ] you do so yeah now I
gave up on that [ __ ]
but not it's so pretty like I love old
school games but a lot of old school
games they're very like like boring
stale I mean like back then and I'm
pretty sure it was like the coolest [ __ ]
I'll play like what game for instance oh
my god I was playing on in double-a like
97 in double-a basketball
oh [ __ ] and I was like yo this is
nothing like ball squeaks yeah where
they dribble the far away from 2k yeah
some of those old games are super hard
though I still love playing all the old
mega man's and I have the Legacy
Collection I've gotten it for every
system I've ever gotten so I've gotten
it for like ps2 ps3 I got it for a
Nintendo switch and I'm probably gonna
get it for ps4 but there's just
something really comforting about
visiting those old games that you grew
up with that you could beat with your
eyes closed nose they're really nice my
play my homies really into Mega Man he
has one of those for the ps2 and like he
can beat the [ __ ] like so like what is
eyes closed wow the music is super
underrated on that stuff too
yeah man like a lot of cool is when I
got into so like I was in a Zelda like I
was into like I was like a little bit
it's a legend is out of there super into
Zelda 2 I probably put in like 200 hours
and I care it's so good have you beat it
like are you doing like yeah beat it
okay okay but there's like you know it's
just like any game like that there's so
many different ways you can beat it you
can just like work through it or you can
just [ __ ] off and do all the side quests
and like two hours dude like I was I was
a fan of Legend of Zelda or like I was
playing it a little bit and then what's
cool is like when I started getting in
some music and like here in certain
beats and I'm like oh [ __ ] that's from
that that's from that video game or like
like my homies will get me into anime
like certain animes and then I'll hear
beats their [ __ ] and be like yo that's
where I came from like a keyboard yeah
like it'll be this it'll be the most
like miniscule thing and I'm like yo
that sounds really like I'll be watching
anime with my girl and like like a
certain like like series of like sounds
start playing I'm like oh yeah that
happened to me like I'm gonna be last
week I mean I'm so [ __ ] out of like
relevance as far as like hip hop right
now but it happened to me last week I
was listening to randomly in the
background I had this FX twin album
playing and one of straight-up it was a
Kanye instrumental from his latest album
or from that I think it was from the
Pablo album life of Pablo and it was the
same instrumental like he literally just
bought that bought the track from aphex
twin yeah I forget what song it was but
I instantly knew I'm like this is the
Kanye this is the same [ __ ] Kanye
song he named a sample II know he just
straight up popped it you just said let
me cop that he probably added like one
little thing to it yeah but it's I mean
it's like the perfect it's the perfect
combination yeah you know I mean like FX
twin beats or FX twin like his
instrumentals and you know if everything
it's like clams Casino and Lil B yeah
like the perfect combo when we talk
about producer rapper duo's there in
like top top five one of the greatest of
all time I'm God are you kidding me okay
top five producer rapper duo's little
bein clams let me say RZA and wu-tang
Waka Flocka and Lex Luger mm-hmm gucci
mane and gucci mane is a yeah and last
but not least i'ma say Metro boomin and
whoever he's working with I must say I'm
gonna say Metro boomin and young thug
hmm I remember well nah I can't even say
that cuz thug like thug got just as many
[ __ ] with tm88 southside that without
warning album all those guys so it's
like it's a toss but yeah Mitch that's
not a little [ __ ] that's not clams
yeah that I stuff brings back members
like a whole era of my life that Lil B
clams casino era
listening to closes and clams but
violate that [ __ ] right before you got
here oh yeah we were jamming sounds like
it's everything just sounds like it's
maxing out bass and everything all at
the same time he had that tight-ass
purple v-neck belly button shirt yo yo
what the [ __ ]
Ruby what's going on with low B's tight
man low B is like Toby might be a alien
dude oh no girl like him and Elon Musk
came from the same planet
dude lobe is incredible like he he has
time to do like he has time to like be
on Twitter all day Instagram all day
reply to all of his friends retweet
everything like everything he replies
the DMS replies that everybody's DMS do
all this [ __ ] on top of that drop like a
hundred song mixtapes oh yeah every
couple months like like little bees to
this day one of the hardest-working you
know I'm saying artists out there he's
definitely out there like dude I
remember okay so when I was in like the
fifth grade that's when vans came out
with the pack and I remember back then
do like no black kids were wearing vans
man so like they they they they put that
[ __ ] at the forefront like yo like this
is what we do like we skate we were vans
we're gonna make this [ __ ] cool is what
we do you know I'm sad man I looked at
is like damn like you know saying like
you can be yourself like you can have
your own taste like you you don't kind
of rock [ __ ] the Jordans and the air
forces and you know yeah yeah you get a
lot of [ __ ] for it you know I got a lot
of [ __ ] for it skateboarding and growing
up but uh yeah I do like when they'll be
started doing his solo thing it was the
same [ __ ] where it was like you know
when he started the bass movement and
being basis basically being whoever you
are just being you yeah I was saying
just
you know just not uh not really trying
to try to impress anybody or you know
I'm saying did you see when he went on
ESPN and he wore the dress with the yes
exactly
yeah he was bro he was on SportsCenter
ESPN I think he was on was the NBA
Finals and they had little B as a guest
speaker on SportsCenter
like in the middle like the most watched
like the most like the part of the year
when like May June during the NBA Finals
is like when ESPN gets its probably its
highest viewership of the year and they
picked like celebrities to come on their
once a week to talk about sports to talk
about their favorite they had little
beyond their wearing a full purple
blouse with long earrings and like a
like a it was like I was a sundress and
he's on another another that when he
dropped the curse yeah yeah was that I
think that was when he lifted the curse
cuz he dropped the curse on Kevin Durant
before that cuz Kevin Durant wouldn't
play him in one-on-one yeah and then and
Kevin Durant called him whack on Twitter
and then so he showed a dress when he
finally showed up that that was when
Katie came back to the came to the
Warriors so he's like Katie came to the
bay I'm lifting the curse on Katie and
he won and he won twice low beat my low
be made a mixtape called hoop life you
know basically just now whole [ __ ] was
based around like he wasn't dissing
Kevin Durant on the whole [ __ ] but like
he dedicated it like [ __ ] Kevin Durant
we play that in the office we're playing
ping-pong and there's a do man in a
basketball court in the video like yeah
play me in a game in one-on-one it's
really fun no the video will be and he's
like he's crying in the pet store yeah
that is the best [ __ ] dude I'll be
feeling like that in the past or now not
I got a lizard so beautiful
[Laughter]